leaders of the more than 850 million
people in Latin America and Europe who
speak Spanish and Portuguese had
gathered in the Dominican Republic under
the banner of creating a more just and
sustainable ibero America
yet it was the passionate plea for
military intervention and
french-speaking Haiti which has been
overrun by criminal gangs that took the
summit by surprise
here we are on the same island of a
failed state with unbridled violence and
the world is again looking the other way
and as a Costa Rican I think it's unfair
to us the Dominican Republic to send its
troops to its neighboring country this
is a global responsibility and we are
ignoring our responsibility
the only way to deal with Haiti is to
pacify it the only way to help IIT is to
pacify it
call came on the heels of a meeting
between US and Canada who reportedly
also debated the option of sending the
stabilizing Forester Haiti
Summit leaders tried primarily to focus
on concrete measures to offset the
ravages of climate change of the
increase in hunger in the region and
also the digital divide but it wasn't
long before sharp divisions amongst them
came to the surface
Chile's president lashed out at
Nicaragua's president who did not attend
for the banishment of hundreds of
opponents
taught us in the most brutal way the
risk of seeing human rights as something
relative never under any pretext can we
allow exceptions that's why esteemed
colleagues we believe it is unacceptable
to remain silent about the family
dictatorship of Ortega and mourillo in
Nicaragua
Colombia's Gustavo Petro said that the
imprisonment of Peru's former president
Pedro Castillo was equivalent to a coup
because he was deposed without a proper
trial
in the end there was at least consensus
on the need to continue working together
on what they can agree on with Spain and
Portugal promising to bring the voice of
Latin America closer to Europe
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Santo Domingo